So every profession has a code of
ethics.
Doctors have a code of ethics.
The hippocratic oath,
lawyers,
accountants,
journalists.
Uh,
in fact,
part of a profession is that there is a
code of ethics and museums and museum
directors have an association and the
code and that code says among other
things,
that you can't sell a work of art from
your collection and use that money to
use to do something else with it.
So for example,
right now the Detroit Institute of art
is battling the city because the city
wants to sell the art so that it can pay
pensions.
How does the director defend himself?
How does,
how does he make a case for this not to
happen?
And Who protects him along with his
board?
And that's where a code of ethics comes
in.
Code of ethics that is developed,
worked on by a group of professionals,
changes over time.
So now we turn to the performing arts.
And for me,
it was a big surprise.
It was a shock actually to hear and to
think about the fact that there really
isn't a code of ethics for the
performing arts.
Uh,
of course,
I did some research just to make sure,
let me give you an example,
and this is a mundane example,
but,
uh,
being a former pianist,
it struck me,
and that is,
uh,
I was at a concert and a string quartet
was playing a Schubert Quartet.
And in the fourth movement,
the first violin is turned to the second
violinist and gave a kind of a nod and
the second violinist gave a kind of a
nod to the cellist.
You get the idea.
And I was thinking to myself,
what are they doing?
I couldn't figure it out.
So they played the piece and what they
did or what they didn't do was they
didn't play the repeat of the first part
of this Schubert Quartet.
Now,
the general audience,
they probably didn't know as a,
as a musician,
I knew,
is it a big deal?
It's not what Schubert intended.
Uh,
so is there some reason,
is there something that we can use to
guide to help us understand what's right
and what's not?
Okay.
That's a mundane example in lots of
people break that or bruits.
So code of ethics about playing repeats.
When I play the piano now of course I
play all the repeats that are necessary.
Uh,
take that a little further though,
uh,
into the realm of what does a producer
do when thinking about what can be and
what can't be done.
Uh,
a couple of years ago,
Diane Paulus,
who's a wonderful director and producer
in Boston,
did a version of porgy and bess,
you know,
one of the classic American operas.
Everybody knows porgy and bess and some
of it is sad and some of it is,
you know,
to some people a little boring.
Uh,
and Diane Paulus decided to do a
completely different version of porgy
and bess.
She decided to,
uh,
make it more modern,
which is fine.
She decided to change the ending,
which is questionable.
She decided to change some of the music.
Now,
you know,
I'm a purist.
This really bothered me,
of course.
So the question is,
can Diane Paulus do that?
Of course she can do it,
but can she call it porgy and bess?
It's now it played on Broadway for a
season as a cast recording.
And in the future,
will there be an understanding by a
generation who thinks that this is what
porgy and bess is?
Okay.
So I don't want to be pedantic about
this but,
but my point is that over and over
again,
there are questions that every
profession has that the members of the
profession have not discussed to say
what's right,
what's wrong and argue about sure.
But there's no basis,
there's no moral basis.
It gets a little more complicated.
There was a production in Berlin,
in Berlin Opera House of a Mozart opera
called in dominium and this producer,
opera director in Berlin and in Berlin,
you know,
they do kind of outlandish kinds of
opera,
decided to do a very outlandish
production in which among other things,
Mohammed was inserted into the opera.
It wasn't in the opera and uh,
took the place of another character.
And for some people,
for some Muslims it seemed like a
sacrilegious thing to do and there was a
big protest.
The question is,
does the head of the opera company say
the director has the right and the
ethical right to do what he thinks is
right or does that person give into
public appeal?
So the answer is who knows?
And the answer is also we don't know
because there isn't this kind of set
rule.
If a doctor is faced with an ethical
choice,
they turned to their code of ethics.
If a museum director is faced with an
ethical choice,
they turn to a code of ethics.
If a performing arts director or a
string quartet leader or a producer on
Broadway is faced with what might be
considered by some an ethical choice,
they have nothing to fall back on,
so to speak.
What we need are a group of
professionals who are in the theater who
can at least discuss it,
who can set the beginnings of a
fundamental of unethical decision or
ethical philosophy.